how's the gum brother money holy [ __ ]
this game it's the most badass game of
all time what is this intro minecart
whoa okay yeah let me play it please
gosh
Fei welcome pilot Poots to altitude
lower and faster it's part of the a zero
Club that's my favorite out of all clubs
yeah we're a pro wait we're not I hope
we approach oh all right let's try this
out oh god this is complicated can't be
that bad
Oh God okay okay I'm here to annoy
thanks balloon okay this is some weird
[ __ ] man there we go dive
Oh oh [ __ ] my up alright I got this Wow
oh no no no no yes no now why would I
boost what in the heavens the controls
man oh [ __ ] now I was not supposed to do
that here we go boost grandma
now that skipping one gate is a kegger
now let [ __ ] this game this [ __ ] game
man this [ __ ] game man I should not
have selected professional that's for
sure and within it what am i doing
alright that's that's one way to finish
it that went pretty well
I'm pretty damn good at this game so far
so out [ __ ] balloons man why do they
exist there we go got it
ah oh god oh god here we go here we go
Bost nailed it that's how it's done yes
yes oh [ __ ] that's that's the rock huh
Oh for [ __ ] sake mate
Oh can we do it oh we did it
ha ha ha now yet not a problem at all oh
my god uh to be completed yet we still
haven't completed the tutorial
ah that's terrible
that's if we can complete this this
tutorial hmm suck on that hey Einstein
I'm on your side there we go here we go
here we go
oh I can slow down why didn't you tell
me oh my gosh all right here we go we
gotta hit that circle we gotta hit that
circle who's that [ __ ] Oh Oh God okay
okay yeah yes yes okay we got to go
faster we got to go faster okay
ah not slower yes Jerris okay we got to
go pull oh god damn it we came so far
too loose it all [ __ ] ah
we almost got perfect I wouldn't really
call it perfect but we almost got
something there it is that has to be
completion no way I'm so done
are you [ __ ] kidding me there we go
let's do this one I can select what the
[ __ ] it is Oh go three please all right
sure why not
all right guys let's do this beauty pack
oh god oh god oh god
now get alright yep got this no problem
we got this thing in a bag in the bag oh
we went through a dog oh my god my god
what happened
hahaha oh that's fantastic Oh a [ __ ]
down nailed it and then through there
got it yeah they didn't got it boost it
no [ __ ] wait yes we got it we got it we
got it we got it
gotta get that boom boom boom yes
and then finish Oh fret like a glove so
well look exactly oh I got I got alright
well I wasn't terrible let's do that
again actually this game is surprisingly
fun holy [ __ ] it's only fun cuz it's so
hard I don't know I don't know if I'd
enjoy it if it was easy
at least the graphics are better than
the Xbox who put the [ __ ] hey there
like hey there your rock star like this
don't fly in the goddamn cliff I swear
to God oh yeah
gosh damn it whoa okay I can fly like
this alright that makes it easier I
think right yeah I be the plane be the
plane
oh I'm bein hello I'm the bane out [ __ ]
oh that's how you say when you hit a
balloon as a plane they see me rollin
number two suck on that
the right event occurs and cramps let's
play again and let's beat them all come
on come on what oh no hmm
ah reposition come on all right
first
bruat ho that's what she said what do we
get what we get what we get there has to
be number one [ __ ] number one
shut up Buddha Sakyamuni shut that booty
slap away yeah yeah what's up I'm number
one number one [ __ ] jump I quite like
the scape it's very exciting
look at that balloon no one's that no
one is in the balloon my plane is yellow
now was it
alright let's boost this boost Oh bear
is ready Gary here okay okay okay okay
okay
all right we did it that was not a gate
aah help help oh yes okay we got it
keep me a lot boost nine oh god what
happened to my plane there we go aah aah
help help
what is happening first whoo first let's
make a loop I don't think that was that
great I don't there's no one in the
plane we got number three let's go for
number one Allah of everyone is equally
terrible like it gives you some
perspective like if I can get number
three then they they are absolutely
horrible at this game oh that was good
how in the okay I'll take good
Oh God Oh all right that was good to
[ __ ] me I guess yes we got rip mochi rat
damage repair oh [ __ ] just stick out man
boost
I can't booze kiss my plane is broken
this game is amazing I love this game my
game ever can out of 10
give me like upgrade stop and [ __ ] now
I'll go with the Thunder think no no
let's cover the air taxi
where's okay boost boost boost [ __ ]
who's that [ __ ] who's that [ __ ]
booster booster boost oh god oh god I
got nailed in I've got oh god oh god
nailed it nailed it
what that [ __ ] is that ah going down
going down I repeat we're going down oh
god what is going on I'm going to space
they sued some team rocket flag a burger
yeah Jesus Christ those meat claws like
are you for real cease oh I think we did
it I think we did it oh [ __ ] got the
ships okay we can't boost now though
we'll just have to go with it [ __ ] [ __ ]
I've got the cliff that cliffhanger Oh
God oh yes
got it get into finish what do we get
five aah aah
whoa what was that alright we're gonna
have to do that again there we go that's
what I'm talking about [ __ ] that's
what I'm talking about [ __ ]
do we even know how to snitches oh god
oh god oh god oh wow oh god oh god that
was not good ah the cliff [ __ ] make
everything in life oh whoa whoa whoa we
try it's harder than it looks
it is hard but it's fun that's what she
said sexual innuendo sexual innuendo
while flying girl while flying [ __ ] Nick
oh god we're going down Mayday Mayday
Mayday Mayday
what the hell ah got it
get that boom boom boom Oh God Oh God
all right this is perfect there we go
that's what I'm talking about
Oh God wasn't the [ __ ] was that yeah
[ __ ] it threw me off
ah no we can still do this no they beat
me I was number one ah all right one
more we can do it we can do this
just hold my hand no wait I need that
hand you were fapping oh god damn it
wash your hands when I ah climb god damn
it where are you going now I was number
one and then they beat me oh no I'm
third again [ __ ]
alright let's come on come on kabaah
come on
can't miss any more gates bill gates
please
what the hell where am I going what ah
ah no I love airplanes this can't crash
no matter what you do they just keep on
going it's kind of inspirational if you
think about it
suck my dick I'm Kim Kardashian yeah I
hate this game yes so good we're doing
so [ __ ] good
oh god oh yes ah stupid balloons boost
boost victory oh the crowd is going wild
can I hear you breasts can I hear you
rose
I can't this is it's not live Plus how
would I hear you anyway you're cute
you're cute that's adorable but we did
it [ __ ] yes we did it bros hack bye I
was easy I'm sweating like a
[ __ ] oh god I'm gonna have to
take a break it's a lot fun I'll leave a
leave a link to this game in the
description if you want to check it out
thank you like in this episode it helps
me out a lot and makes me do it is it
supports me and that makes me happy it
makes me happy to know you do that
that's all for me stay awesome Rose I
know you will ro face